one of the thing I'm constantly talking
about is hierarchy the notion that the
world exists through these hierarchies
of meaning and the consequences of what
happens when those hierarchies break
down and I thought that I would give a
very particular example that we're
seeing today which is in the rise of
social media we are actually seeing the
we would call the reign of chaos and it
doesn't look like only look like a kind
of mush you know you can imagine
something decomposing and becoming a
kind of of incoherent mush but rather it
appears as the succeeding tyrannies you
could say as a form of all these mini
tyrannies which pop up and try to assert
themselves
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
so in our society we've been seeing the
notion of hierarchy breakdown
ever since for several hundred years by
now and we're seeing accelerate in in
the 20th century and in the 21st century
with post-modernism this notion that
hierarchy itself is bad that we talk
about multiplicity we talk about all
these terms which tend to emphasize
diversity and all of that now one of the
difficulties that happens when chaos
starts to rain is that it ends up
actually looking like a bunch of little
tyrannies one of the things that I
noticed my first glimpse of that was
actually when I lived in Congo and in
Kinshasa the state had broken down we
were living in a state of chaos and so
that did look like a kind of lawlessness
a kind of Farwest reality where anything
can happen anything can can anything
goes but it also manifested itself
explicitly giving room for little
tyrants you know warlord type figures or
people who could abuse their power so in
in a state of chaos a a a policeman can
abuse their authority much more because
there's impunity there's no structure to
judge his actions and so encountering a
police officer for example as you're
driving can become your worst nightmare
because that person is going to impose
themselves on you like a little tyrant
and so I had to deal with that quite a
bit when I was in Congo um
I tried to get myself out of sticky
situations where I had been stopped by
the police and they were trying to get
some money out of me or or some kind of
impose their their power on me and so
when someone has a weapon that is
obviously can become a very scary thing
now
obviously most people have not been in
Congo or in those types of countries but
we can see something like that happening
right now on social media and we can see
it happening especially through Twitter
now as we're watching let's say
the narratives break down as we're
watching the narratives fragment social
media is becoming a series of little
tyrannies and what do I mean by that now
one of the ways that the little
tyrannies have been we've been seeing
the little tyrannies appear in our space
is the notion of fashion so the notion
that something becomes fashionable and
then goes out of fashion is a caricature
of a tyranny and so in a world where
people are not turned towards a common
goal a common purpose a common Center
then our desire for centers is not going
away that's how we're made were made to
desire something which which brings
things together focuses our attention
focuses our our desires our energy into
one direction that's just how human
beings are made so in the absence of a
all-encompassing Center something which
transcends us and which kind of brings
us together what ends up happening is
not just a bunch of random occurrences
but rather the appearance of extremely
strong points of interests that succeed
each other and so what it does is the
breakdown of hierarchy accelerates time
what do I mean by that now fashion is a
good way to see that so in fashion what
you can see is things appearing you know
all of a sudden everybody is everybody
has a everybody has a mullet and then
it's the mullet is the thing to do and
everybody's getting a mullet and a
mullet and a mullet and then all of a
sudden it falls out of fashion and then
you're an idiot to have a mullet you're
such a [ __ ] and we've seen that happen
quite rapidly what is it a year and a
half ago every single child in the world
had a little hand spinner and you
everywhere you would go you see these
children with little hand spinners and
then a year later they're all gone
they've all disappeared and so you can
see that happen in all kinds of domains
in music in in
fashion you know in all kinds of
cultural manifestations because you know
because we're not focused on a
transcendent ideal because we're not
looking towards something which will
stabilize the hierarchies where we
actually end up having all these little
things pop up and succeed each other in
rapid succession you know and so that's
what I mean by it's what it does is it
actually accelerates time and I think
most people can feel that time is
accelerating right now
most people can feel that the world is
accelerating and part of this has to do
with the breakdown in a normal hierarchy
because of the rapid succession
succession of what you would call
focuses of attention in terms of what's
happened and so we can see that now with
this whole idea of the news cycle and
all these crazy news cycles that that
that pop up and these things that appear
another thing that can help you
understand the problem of these little
tyrannies is of course the whole idea of
something going viral
the very name viral is a great name for
what that is because a virus is exactly
that a virus or a disease is a breakdown
in hierarchy of your body there's a
breakdown in the normal functioning in
the normal hierarchy of the body and
there's something there's a disease or a
microbe a parasite which all of a sudden
takes up all the attention and becomes
and so in in the breakdown of the bodily
hierarchy what is there's a little
tyranny which appears and then which
will draw all your energy draw all your
attention into that parasitic thing and
so the idea of videos going viral a post
going viral it's exactly that something
appears all of a sudden and everybody's
talking about it what was it that crazy
meme about what's-her-name was it Momo
or something some some hoax online about
an evil this evil thing that people were
doing and then within in a few days
everybody was talking about it my whole
Twitter feed my whole Facebook feed was
full of people who are talking about
this one thing and then a week later
it's as if it never happened and so the
idea of
of virality is a caricature of the the
desire that we have for focusing our
attention for focusing our are focusing
in a hierarchy and so you can see that
there's an analogy in that to our own
self into our own bodies and so giving
into a passion is exactly that when we
when we give into when when the normal
hierarchy of our being let's say with
our with meaning as being first with
with our our spiritual identity as being
first once that starts to break down we
now start to focus on lower things and
we get these these little tyrannies now
the little tyranny could be an obsession
with with the food it could be an
obsession with eating chocolate or
eating certain things um it can be all
kinds of desires that pop up and that
completely suck away your attention into
that desire you know pornography is
probably one of the the best examples
because it fragments into all these
little types all these little genres and
every little genre becomes this
obsessive thing where people focus only
on that one genre and so it becomes this
strange tyranny of attention that will
drag people into it and will take up all
their their attention and so this is a
phenomena that we're seeing all over the
place and one of the the symptoms of
this breakdown is of course the way that
Twitter works the the amazing thing
about Twitter is it it shows you what it
means for there not to be hierarchy and
so on Twitter you know you have all
these people speaking it's even crazier
because a lot of them are anonymous and
so you have all these you have all this
bubbling up of all these little things
that people are saying and a lot of them
are anonymous and so what kept what
happens is that you the media on either
side can draw a narrative any narrative
that they want and and they can increase
the breakdown of culture by doing that
now let me give you an example
let
say something happens in the world let's
say there's a shooting like we saw in
New Zealand and so someone in the the
media will write an article and say
people on Twitter are saying this and
then they will find the craziest thing
that they can find on Twitter and they
will put it up there someone who says
because of the New Zealand shooting we
need to ban Jordan Peterson and ban sam
Harris and ban all these people from the
the platform and so you know other
people are freaking out because all the
sudden people on Twitter are saying this
and it's like who are these people on
Twitter we don't even know who they are
they're there they've just been there
this sea of crazy chatter of tweets of
Twitter exactly of a kind of inane
chattering and then someone points to
that and pull something out and says
this is reality this tweet that I found
here that maybe has 12 likes or even if
it has a thousand likes it doesn't
matter it's nothing in the main in the
main narrative but they point they take
it out and they say here this is reality
and so you can see how the the absence
of of hierarchy and the absence of a
hierarchy of meaning really does create
this strange this strange capacity to
make anything all of a sudden make it
make anything real and that's what
happens with the absence of authority
that and the fact that every voice is
somehow equal that we actually do
believe that every single voice is equal
means that you can just pull out some
random voice and you can write an
article saying this is what people are
saying on Twitter and you can have four
or five you can have ten ten tweets oh
look at these ten tweets that are saying
things that that that that caused me
outrage or ten tweets that are saying
things that I agree with and so look at
what two people on Twitter are saying
and what's crazy about Twitter
especially Twitter is that we don't know
who those people are they could actually
be people who are pretending to be what
that what is there we have no way of
knowing whether who
our width aren't what their intentions
are and and and on what side there are
you know every time someone will will
put up some tweet of someone saying
something crazy you always have to ask
yourself the question is it someone from
their side who's putting up something
crazy so that they can then point to it
and then say look at what the other side
are saying we have we have no way of
knowing and that's really the the the
very notion of the incapacity to discern
which comes in this breakdown of
hierarchy and the breakdown of meaning
and so you can see and then you can also
see how in the breakdown of a normal
hierarchy what ends up happening is you
start to get these warring sides and
because there's no way of qualitatively
distinguishing voices and qualitatively
distinguishing information what they'll
end up doing is they can point to they
can point to little things on the other
side that exist but that are not
important in the hierarchy and they
could say see see look this is this is
why we want we oppose them this is why
we're against them and so that ends and
because there's nothing to bring us
together
there's no transcendent ideal to to move
us in the same direction there is no way
to discern and because the problem is
that the facts that are being quoted are
true it is true that there are people on
Twitter saying crazy things you can
point to the tweets and there they are
so you'll see all people people you
people on the left but also people on
the right you give people online even
people like sargon of akkad who will
make entire videos pulling out tweets on
Twitter which he thinks are insane and
then making fun of them on his on his
podcast as if as if those tweets are
anything but a bunch of gibbering
chatter from people that you don't know
who they are they could be twelve years
old they could be LARPing they could be
they could be you know pretending to be
their enemy in order to mock them and
you know and we saw that even
conservatives got caught up in
you know when they did that I forget the
name of the group that did it but they
did these studies about sexual predators
and dogs and you know they they
published it on a on a liberal in a
little in a kind of left-leaning Journal
and the the more conservative or more
straight journalists got caught up and
saw that at something which was actually
real you know and and then the people on
the other side also thought that it was
real but it was someone pretending to be
their enemy in order to make their enemy
accept things that maybe they wouldn't
even have accepted without without that
happening see that that type of insane
you know incapacity to discern that is
what it looks like
it when there's an absence of hierarchy
and it ends up looking like a rapid
succession of little tyrannies which
will only speed up guys it's only going
to get go faster and faster you know the
the new cycle now is absolutely insane
and not only is it insane but the speed
at which we forget the previous new
cycle is also insane because that is
also a thing that is necessarily going
to happen when hierarchy breaks down
hierarchy is memory hierarchy is the
manner in which things remember their
purpose even though they're far away
from it that hierarchy is a form of
normal memory and as hierarchy breaks
down in society as the common purpose
the common goal the common Direction
breaks down then one of the things that
will break down is also memory and so
these these rapid succession of little
tyrannies that are quickly relegated to
the past and we just move on to the next
one and we see this getting faster and
faster as the cycles accelerate and the
only you know I wish I could tell you
what the the solution is in terms of
society sadly I cannot but I can only
help you understand the problem see it
in your own lives and turn up in terms
of this also these tyrannies of desires
you experience and how they also let's
say pull you away from the normal
hierarchy from your normal purpose that
the the things that you really would
like to want or like to value and see
how this is a pattern with rep which
manifests itself at all different levels
and if we can at least work on our own
let's say passions and our own little
tyrannies our own desire to give in to
fashion to give in to fashionable ideas
to give in to the the clickbait the rage
mate you know the this this kind of mob
mentality where we move from from from
scandal to scandal because the scandal
is exactly that as well a scandal is a
kind of inverted hierarchy where some
some dark thing appears as attracting
all their attention so if if we want to
get away from that we have to start we
have to start with ourselves and and
hopefully it will help us then also pull
away from the other from the other
scandals and so maybe that will also
help all of you to understand why I am
very careful and I I try to not comment
too much on current events and I know
that this might seem strange to some but
the idea that these current events are
meaningful is extremely dubious we need
to be able to pull away from current
events and see the patterns but when we
get caught up in this succession of
current events of some of some of Donald
Trump's latest tweet or Justin Trudeau's
latest idiotic thing that he said you
know to the media we are losing we lose
the capacity to pull away and to view
patterns in in a in a bigger sense and
so I can only I can only plead for
everybody to take the time to do that in
your life and also as you look at
society as a whole so thanks again guys
and I will see you soon